petite vidéo regardez une petite
question à ma question est la suivante
étant donné qu'il ya pas mal de
problèmes de comportement et et
d'hyperactivité de violences et de
dégradations de matériel j'aurais aimé
savoir si grave et les regrets
concernant certains de mes camarades
criminalité avec des compagnies et
decker ou des intercalaires dur de quoi
de quoi il s'agit voilà as tu des
regrets concernant ton voilà tu as créé
2 etienne est élu et j'en passe et des
meilleurs merci beaucoup de conneries
[Applaudissements]
c'est clair le plupart des plus drôles
de française aulas d'or il cède alors si
j'ai des regrets non comment ça non
aucun regret m'a demandé il assume aucun
regret fait un caca dans les chaussures
sam stein meurt c'est au contraire je
regrette rien des vols comme all caf pas
des vols
pourquoi ne pas voler des fleurs agathe
à jour pour les offrir à quelqu'un de
solide alors j'ai quelque chose à vous
avouer agathe c'était pas la saga contre
comme ça l'a dernièrement je sais pas si
t'es pas une offense non ces annonces
parce que c'était la journée de la femme
le 8 mars
je croiserai 7 et 8 mars et le 8 mars
c'est l'anniversaire de soria notre asso
ce que j'aime énormément et agathe
garçons
alors je sais pas qui c'est c'est
peut-être notre mec qui vous a envoyé
des fleurs sur la vérité ce soir j'ai
intercepté les fleurs il a émis des
fleurs et des chocolats
elle a raté un dos à cause de la il y
avait des fleurs et des chocolats et
laisser les chocolats et comme ces
anniversaires de soria j'ai offert des
fleurs c'est m'a dit que c'est moi qui
les avais je sais que c'est moche
le mec le mec s'appelait alors on a une
image du temps parce qu'en fait il me
filmer ces cons je sais pas dans les
couloirs
quand je suis offert les fleurs à sans
rien
[Musique]
tout est à vendre
l'accompagnement garde c'est ce que
votre mec s'appelle dit oh non c'est mon
fils les fleurs bizarres